here are the nominees the 2018
Australia's local hero from Queensland
pip Russel so even though we say that
Joost is the TV show made by the kids in
hospital for all the kids in hospital
that's really the end product so it all
starts with the immediate distraction
and the entertainment that we're
bringing in I don't really know if
there's any words that can really
describe that but it makes my heart
smile from Tasmania Judy Adams when you
are passionate about what you do and
when you convey that to people
it certainly sweeps other people up in
that so I don't have the ability to cure
cancer but I do have the ability to
raise funds to support research from
South Australia and rákóczi Costello I
love flying the flag for South Australia
and I've been doing it now for 16 years
we use that TV show to promote not just
regional South Australia and the great
places you can visit but also I'm an
advocate for job growth and creation
here in the state from Victoria that
Boat L being told
four years ago that I would be made
redundant from the automotive industry
was the biggest turning point in my life
I decided to use my engineering skills
to give back to society and help people
with disabilities from Western Australia
Peter Linden James having spent 26 years
in institutions and prisons while living
the life that I've lived this actually
taught me what it is that I know and
it's equipped me what it is that I do
not for harm
not to tear down to build up not to
dispose but together for New South Wales
ad whoo
I go to school every day to awaken
curiosity and discovery in my students
every child should know their life has a
purpose and education will help them
find it my dream is the kids will
approach learning and math law with fear
or anxiety or with joy and excitement
from the Northern Territory
Betina dengan bar by me happy and
standing up for domestic or family
violence victims it makes me feel very
very good inside to be able to see
families living happily from the ICT
Susanne tanks when I see a child coming
into our Center who otherwise has not
been able to access these sort of
services it just melts my heart to see
them laughing singing clapping that's
what childhoods all about and every
child should be able to just be a child
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the definition of hero is someone with
exceptional courage fortitude and skill
whose celebrated for their exploits we
just saw eight heroes right there to
tell us who is the chosen one for 2018
here's our Prime Minister Australia's
local hero for 2018 is Eddie woo
[Applause]
my parents moved from Malaysia to
Australia because they dreamed of a life
for their children where we have access
to education schools and universities
that would just open up a huge world of
possibility
when I was in primary school I was one
of the very few Asians and growing up
and so I was isolated and sort of
bullied and harassed and so I don't even
further into just learning and studies
because I found joy in there my interest
in math started surprisingly late when I
was in high school I didn't find it
difficult or challenging so much as
perplexing I didn't have a huge
understanding of why I was doing it or
how come these answers made sense it was
at university where I actually
challenged myself to really deeply
understand where the fundamentals of
this subject which I'm gonna now try and
teach to children around the country my
first day teaching at school I walked in
and all these hundreds of kids poured
into the school grounds and there was
just this energy and excitement about
where are we gonna go today what are we
gonna discover and from that moment I
was just caught well mister rule always
came in and dancing in the classroom
who's so happy energetic it was an
inspiring but to be around back in 2012
I taught us two who was just in year 10
and he was very very ill he was
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer
immediately we use that he would miss
huge portions of time at school and I
thought it would just be so sad for all
that I could do to be here's a textbook
we'll see you in a month good luck I
took my phone out of my pocket I set it
on a little wooden contraption that I
made down in our woodwork room at the
school just so it wouldn't fall over and
I hit record and I just wanted this one
boy to be able to participate in that
with us even when he was
I started sharing them online just
because that seemed to be the most
convenient way for him to access them
and before I knew it all kinds of other
students were having a look at the
videos using them for a revision people
not now class people not now school
people might now country we've sort of
been going towards zero but in smaller
chunks okay I want to get get faster
okay so this time Tom what should happen
is it's probably the most impressive
thing to me about that is that he was
able to come up with a decision and go
well if I do this this is gonna help
this cube that student graduated he's
long gone he's in university now but I
realized that I should continue making
these videos because they're helpful to
students to parents and teachers
everywhere i watch some of these videos
and I'm just like okay oh I hadn't
thought of it that way I hadn't
explained it that way I've even had a
student stop me in class and go that's
how mr. Wu explains it a teacher mystery
doesn't just change our outlook on math
he changed my outlook on like every
learning experience I guess it is
absolutely an outstanding advocate for
public education
he's a wonderful teacher a great role
model for our students he's a great role
model for our staff I never set out to
create something huge or amazing I
didn't set out to achieve something
great all I wanted to achieve was
something good I just wanted to help one
person that's all I was doing if you
have a heart for helping others if that
motivates you then you'll create
something of value and that's what
excites me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and he congratulated
you're very handsome the walk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll put it back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Prime Minister thank you to
the Ngunnawal people who steward this
beautiful land thank you to the
Commonwealth Bank and the Department of
Home Affairs most of all Thank You
Australia I stand before you not as an
individual it was a proud representative
of every teacher around the country who
Labor's day after day year after year
because we know the power of giving a
child the priceless gift of an education
[Applause]
education can radically change the
trajectory of a child's life it can
transform the possibilities of what a
child can become and achieve that can
change a life a family and a community
forever five years ago I started posting
my lessons online to help other people
learn about maths but when I did I
learned something about maths too I've
learned that while mathematics is hard
it's something everyone wants to
understand once upon a time we thought
that reading and writing were unusual
skills reserved for special people in
society now we know literacy is
essential for everyone my conviction is
that the same is true of mathematics
mathematics is for everyone it's the key
to unlocking a universe of beautiful
patterns practical solutions and
surprising connections and that universe
beckons to all of us if we just embrace
it I'm honored to receive this award but
the truth is I am no more a hero than
anyone else there's nothing special or
extraordinary about my classroom all
I've done is open a window through the
internet to the hard work and dedication
that happens every day in schools around
the country so today I call on every
Australian to truly value education we
often forget how precious and
life-changing school can be but
educators need society's personal and
financial support to do their jobs and
make school a positive experience for
every child almost half of all new
teachers leave the profession in their
first five years because they realize
they carry the burden of a child's
future
while so often being questioned and
criticized by the very society they're
trying to serve that needs to change
while this award is a wonderful step in
the right direction prizing education
isn't really about what we do in
ceremonies and special occasions it's
about what we do every single day in the
way that we think and speak and make
decisions about our country's schools
every Australian must play our part in
honoring our schools and those who work
in them our children and future
generations are depending on it thank
you congratulations to eddi-rue boy did
I made him in my mathematical life a few
years ago show me wasn't at my school I
did have great teachers though just not
quite as enthusiastic about as
mathematics as I should be two Awards
down two more Awards to go and still to
come tonight some legendary Australian
music from some of our most celebrated
musicians that's a real treat coming up
for you but before we get to that I
thought we might find out how our
amazing finalists actually get here
they're actually nominated they're
nominated by you so if there's somebody
in your life or somebody in your local
community who you think deserves
recognition all you have to do is
nominate them just like Geoffrey Wang
lovely to meet you just like you did
with Eddie Wu no come here just a little
bit closer so I can get you in the
camera shot don't be don't be shy it's
all good why did you nominate Eddie well
when I heard about Eddie story he was an
absolute inspiration to me as you can
see from the Asian strain community
there are thousands just like him that's
doing incredible things you know they're
doctors teachers nurses policemen and I
believe that people like Eddie should be
held up in high regard as an example of
the contribution that these people from
ethnic and minority backgrounds actually
making to this great wonderful country
of ours and I you know he was just great
seeing his story he is he's got this
channel that goes out to hundreds of
thousands of students
inspiring you know making math cool yeah
and and even the most disadvantaged
remote and regional kids could actually
have the same access to the best
teachers best teaching material such as
Eddy because of the initiatives that
he's taken upon himself so I'm so proud
of him and our community is just so
proud to have someone like him to you
know show the contribution we have to
this country I have to ask you is it
made you more enthusiastic about maths I
always loved math I'm not going to lie
oh so you're a mathematician yourself
yes and I a sense of mathematical bias
what are you CID doing in the future how
how do you see his influence providing
you know potentially it could be
International given how many followers
he's got on YouTube we - I I hope so I
hope you ever revolutionize education
and the teaching of math you know we
needed in this country we could do with
more stem expertise and and hopefully
that will bring prosperity and jobs back
here Jeffrey it's been wonderful talking
to you thank you so much and and what
before I let you go they what is it like
watching someone that you've nominated
win I'm just so proud of Eddie this is
unreal thank you very much Jeffrey thank
you Jeffrey Wang there ladies and
gentlemen and it's sad it's relatively
easy to nominate somebody you know all
you have to do is get online
Kumi have you if you put that nomination
in you funny you ask Chris some b80 age
right that's it yes jump online
Australian of the Year oh okay you I
don't know if you can self nominate I
did try but something kind of kicked
back it's really easy though it's all
about just looking out in your community
and finding people around you who are
just doing really great things yeah and
as we've seen tonight already I mean you
shine a light on some pretty remarkable
people don't you